معنا من مستشفى ناصر في خان يونس مراسل
الجزيره وائل الدحدوح وائل ماذا في اخر
التطورات الميدانيه كما
رصدتها اخر التطورات هو استمرار القصف
الاسرائيلي المدفعي استمرار الغارات
الاسرائيليه وابرز تلك الغارات بالتاكيد
كانت
استهداف شارع الشارع القريب من مجمع ناصر
الطبي او مستشفى ناصر وتحديدا على بواب
مقر الدفاع المدني المجاور لهذا المستشفى
في في قلب مدينه خان يونس عندما استهدفت
احدى المسيرات الاسرائيليه وقذائف مدفعيه
هذه المنطقه التي تعتبر هي الشارع الرئيسي
وشريان الحياه والاكثر اكتظاظا بالنسبه
للماره وال البائعين وهو تحول ليس فقط الى
طريق وانما الى سوق لعرض البضائع بالنسبه
للمواطنين الفلسطينيين و وبالتالي هذه
المنطقه وهذه الساعه تعتبر ذروه نشاط
وتحركات المواطنين الفلسطينيين عندما استه
استهدفت هذه المنطقه هذا الامر ادى الى
سقوط ثمانيه شهداء وعدد كبير من الجرحى
نقلوا الى المستشفى لتلقي العلاج من بين
هؤلاء بالتاكيد هي احدى سيارات الاسعاف
التي كانت تقل بعض المرضى قادمه بهم الى
مجمع ناصر الطبي عندما استهدفه القصف
الامر الذي ادى الى تضرر السياره واصابه
المرضى بداخل هذه السياره ومن ثم قامت
رجال الاسعاف بربما انتشال بعض الجثامين
الشهداء الذين سقطوا خلال هذه الغاره
بالتاكيد هناك غارات اخرى في منطقه عبسان
على سبيل المثال هناك ثلاثه شهداء ايضا
باستهداف مجموعه من
المواطنين باحدى المسيرات الاسرائيليه
وهناك ايضا استهدافات اخرى مختلفه في
مناطق مختلفه من خانيونس الامر الذي ادى
الى استشهاد نحو 22 شهيدا في اجمال هذه
الاستهدافات حتى الان لكن في مناطق اخرى
مثل
منطقه المغازي المصدر وايضا بعض مناطق في
وسط قطاع غزه تعرضت هي الاخرى لعمليات قصف
مدفعي مركز لكن الابرز هو استخدام سياسه
الاحزمه الناريه والغارات العنيفه من اجل
تدمير عدد كبير من المنازل في قريه المصدر
وايضا في مخيم المغازي وهي مناطق ايه
تعتبر مخلاه وغير ماهوله باعتبار ان
اصحابها نزحوا عنها تحت استمرار الضربات
والقصف المدفعي الضربات الجويه والقصف
المدفعي وياتي تاتي هذه الغارات والاحزمه
الناريه لتدمير هذه المنازل في امعانا في
عمليه التخريب وتدمير المنازل اسوه في
مناطق اخرى مثل منطقه خانيونس التي تعتبر
الان ذروه عمليات التفجير والقصف بالغارات
الجويه تستهدف اساسا تدمير اهم البنايات
واهم العمارات السكنيه في المنطقه المكتظه
والمنطقه الاكثر حيويه في محافظه خانيونس
وهذا اصبح ربما نهج تنتهجه قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في معظم المحافظات لا سما تلك
التي تشهد عمليات مناورات بريه او تشهد
توغلات اسرائيليه وكذلك اشتباكات مع فصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في هذه المناطق طيب
وائل ايضا شاهدنا قبل قليل صورا لجرحى
ومصابين في داخل مستشفى ناصر في خان يونس
طبعا اقتضاب كبير في ظل يعني تراجع كبير
في الامكانات الامكانات الطبيه قربنا اكثر
من هذا المشهد لو
سمحت
في نهايه المطاف مجمع ناصر الطبي قسم
الاستقبال والطوارئ هو اصلا مكتظ بالجرحى
يتواجد فيه اعداد كبيره من الجرحى عندما
ياتي الى هذا القسم اعداد كبيره اضافيه
دفعه واحده في غارتين خلال يعني بضعه
دقائق هذا الامر بالتاكيد يضغط اكثر ولا
يجد طواقم الطواقم الطبيه لا يجدون اسره
التعامل مع هذه الاعداد فيضطر الى التعامل
معهم على الارض وفي زوايا وجنبات هذا
القسم قسم الاستقبال والطوارئ لكنها ليست
العقبه الوحيده بالتاكيد هي عقبه كبيره
بحيث تؤثر على الاداء الطبي في نهايه
المطاف وكيفيه التعامل بجوده مع هذه
الاصابات التي تاتي تباعا لكن بالتاكيد
هناك استنزاف كبير لمخزون الادويه
العلاجات المستلزمات الطبيه جراء هذه
الاعداد التي تاتي تباعا في كل يوم وليس
فقط هذا اليوم او خلال الساعتين الماضيتين
ولكن استمرار هذه الاعداد الكبيره هذا
بالتاكيد يضغط على مخزون العلاجات
والادويه والمستلزمات
الطبيه وايضا يضغط على قضيه الاجهزه
المستخدمه كثيره هي الاجهزه التي تصاب
باعطال فنيه لكن لا تجد من يقوم باعمال
الصيانه لها باختصار شديد لانه لا توجد
قطع غيار لا توجد ادخال اجهزه او اخراج
الاجهزه من اجل صيانتها وهذا الامر
بالتاكيد يعرقل عمل الاطقم الطبيه التي هي
الاخرى تعتبر تعاني اكثر ما تعاني من حاله
الاستنزاف المستمر في ظل قله الكادر وكثره
الاعداد والاعباء الطبيه المستمره جراء
استمرار الغارات والاصابات باعداد كبيره
وبالتالي هذا الطاقم اصبح منهكا بشكل كبير
جراء كل هذه الاعباء لذلك الواقع الصحي او
الواقع الطبي يعتبر واقع منهك جدا جدا جدا
في منطقه خانيونس ومناطق اخرى منطقه رفح
على سبيل المثال وكل ما ياتي من المعبر
بالتاكيد تدخل كميات لكنها كميات محدوده
لا تتناسب مع حجم النزيف في مخزون الادويه
والعلاجات والمستلزمات الطبيه اشكرك جزيل
الشكر من مستشفى ناصر في خان يونس وائل
الدحدوح